no
[Música]
todos en la vida pasamos por momentos
difíciles un divorcio
una perdida una mala decisión pero la
diferencia entre unos y otros seres
humanos es como enfrentamos estos
momentos difíciles en la vida
pero al final cada una de esas
experiencias va a aportar algo a
nuestras vidas
y siempre va a depender de dos
parámetros número uno la actitud y
número dos la mentalidad
si bien es cierto que todo parte de un
evento al cual nos hace tener una
creencia y esa creencia nos hace vivir
una realidad ojo mi realidad no es
necesariamente la verdad pongo un
ejemplo el evento es un divorcio mi
creencia es que yo no creo en las
relaciones de pareja
y mi realidad es que me empieza a costar
trabajo relacionarme con personas en
cuestión de citas me invitan a salir o
invito a salir a alguien y ya de
antemano voy con mi escudo y mi espada
desenvainada 2 y ni siquiera ha empezado
a convivir
lo que tenemos que hacer es dar un paso
atrás modificar nuestra creencia para
poder vivir una realidad mucho más
pegada a la verdad
bien dicen que
el peor enemigo del hombre es su mente
por eso hoy les vengo a compartir el
triángulo chingón
y no se alarmen con este término pues
esta palabra es el verbo más conjugado y
es el adjetivo más usado nuestra cultura
mexicana no por algo existe el singular
yo escrito por maría del pilar montes de
boca que habrá del uso de uso y abuso
del chingar y sus derivados
y lo que pretende este triángulo es muy
sencillo es analizar nuestros
pensamientos de una manera mucho más
fácil y mucho más concreta así que sin
más preámbulo comencemos
en la primera punta del triángulo está
la chingadera
en esta punta hacemos nosotros las cosas
por obligación y la característica
principal es que todas mis frases
empiezan con la palabra tengo tengo que
ir a la oficina tengo que ir a la
escuela tengo que ir al gimnasio tengo
que ponerme a dieta
tengo que lavar los platos y cuando mi
cerebro demanda esa señal a mi cuerpo de
que estamos haciendo las cosas por
obligación empezamos a reaccionar de
diferentes maneras
irritables tensos presionados en pocas
palabras nos ponemos neuróticos
les practicó algo estábamos en un grupo
de trabajo de consultores en una ocasión
y cuando estábamos en lo más asumido del
problema de la problemática de la
empresa
una amiga consultora se para y nos dice
les dejo porque tengo que ir por mis
hijos al fútbol y ese es el momento en
el que les platico porque yo te podría
dar tres opciones para demostrarte que
no tienes que ir por tus hijos a fútbol
puedes pedir el favor a un familiar
puedes pedir el favor a un amigo o
puedes pedirle el favor a otra mamá o
papá que vaya por su hijo y te lo
regrese a tu casa
y así poder solucionar esa problemática
que tanto está congoja de tener que ir
por tus hijos al fútbol
luego entonces
si tú analizas estas tres opciones y aún
así decides ir por tus hijos del fútbol
te felicito acabas de pasar a la segunda
punta del triángulo la chingo nería
a diferencia que en la primera haces las
cosas por obligación en esta punta las
lajas por decisión y la característica
principal es que mis frases empiezan con
la palabra quiero yo quiero ir a la
oficina yo quiero ir a la escuela
yo quiero ir al gimnasio yo quiero
ponerme a dieta yo quiero lavar los
platos y si me presionan hasta el agua y
plancho
pero al final lo que estamos buscando es
precisamente eso mi cerebro capta que
estoy haciendo las cosas por decisión
propia y le manda ese mensaje a mi
cuerpo y empezamos a mandar un mensaje
de relax estamos mucho más relajados yo
les preguntaría esta persona de la cara
de la que hablábamos anteriormente que
tenía que ir por sus hijos al fútbol
ustedes creen que iría con el mismo
carácter a buscar a sus hijos cuando
estaba en el modo de obligación que
cuando lo tomó por decisión
por supuesto que no cuando iba en el
modo chingadera apenas los hijos se
subieron al auto mira qué sucio vienes
viene del fútbol no parte desde el
asiento seguro no has hecho tu tarea
ahorita que llegues a la casa vas a
arreglar tu cuarto
y en dos semanas de dos semanas se dio
cuenta de que cuando se pasó al modo
chingón hería las cosas cambiaron empezó
a preguntar cosas como cómo te fue en el
entrenamiento cuántos goles metiste
quién vino a entrenar cuando esté el
próximo partido
y es ahí justo ahí en donde escalamos la
cúspide de este maravilloso triángulo
que es el yachting
se les platico mejor se los explico
mejor es como si tú fueras simba y rafik
y te tomará de los brazos y se levantará
te presentará ante la selva la sociedad
de la selva como el próximo rey león'
mejor aún es como si fueras leonardo
dicaprio en la punta del titanic
gritando a los cuatro vientos and the
king of the world porque justo en ese
momento es lo que eres el rey del mundo
y nada ni nadie puede bajarte de ahí más
que tú mismo porque así como la mente es
chingón
también es cabrona pero tú decides qué
lado es el que quieres que predomine en
tu vida
está el ajuste de este triángulo lo
lograste es y llegarás a estar allá es
que lo lograste por disciplina y por
persistencia
y porque ya puedes hacer lo que quieras
cuando quieras donde quieras con quien
quieras
no te voy a mentir estar en la punta de
ese triángulo no es nada sencillo
alguna vez estarás de un lado nosotros
en el otro miraras a favor de las
maneras de las manecillas del reloj
tiradas en contra de ellas pero al final
necesitas tener entrenamiento de alto
rendimiento para estar ahí
es como si jugarás béisbol en las
grandes ligas
es como si preparadas a tu equipo de
fútbol para ganar la copa del mundo o
aquel pintor que está pintando su obra
maestra o aquel actor que está
preparándose para el papel para ganarse
el oscar eso es la punta del triángulo
y eso cambiar el chip mental para esto
es una cuestión de decisión tu decisión
es una cuestión de actitud tu actitud
por eso a todos aquellos que están
cansados casados con la frase de
es que no eres tú soy yo
les tengo una noticia tiene razón pero
no son ustedes es su cerebro por eso te
pregunto de que el lado del triángulo
quieres estar
cuando yo preparaba esta práctica desde
el año pasado para exponerlos a ustedes
la primera vez que la vi ante un grupo
reducido de personas un amigo de entre
ellos me dijo oye juanma y tú ya
chingaste
y mi respuesta hasta el día de hoy es no
pero estoy a punto de chingar ya lo digo
el 'chicharito' hace unos meses
imaginemos las cosas sin ganas
yo te voy a dar otra frase para que te
ley eres clavada en la mente y es
hagamos cosas chingón as muchas gracias
[Aplausos]